I spoke at the University of Buffalo in
the spring of this year and I speak at a
lot of campuses around the country every
single year even as the administrations
try to shut down a lot of those and
that's been happening this semester as
well still I go I go there and we Face
protests from students sometimes I was
just at Cornell there was a small
protest we Face protests from outside
activists anarchists antifa that
sometimes there's more of them in
Pittsburgh they burn me an effigy and
threw an explosive at the building when
I walked on
stage but the craziest part is we Face
protests from the administrations of
these universities even public
universities we Face protests from the
politicians and when I spoke at
University of Buffalo you had not only
the U Buffalo Administration you had the
Sunni State University of New York
Administration you had the governor of
New York Kathy hokel come out against me
attack me before I ever spoke and I was
speaking on the subject of men and women
being different I I was giving a lecture
on a subject that everyone should have
been taught in kindergarten at the
absolute latest and should be
uncontroversial after that point these
days were very confused so I gave it a
speech on that very basic I think
broadly ought to be an offensive point
and we had protests from everybody and
then the school chapter of the young
Americas Foundation was cancelled
afterward the the young Americas
Foundation chapter uh was threatened
with removal they had to sue yav had to
sue the allian to Freedom had to sue and
now the student who brought me Connor
Agri testified before the house
Judiciary Committee in front of Jim
Jordan and other members of Congress
imagine how far our country's Fallen
that this young man had to testify
before the United States Congress on why
conservatives ought to be allowed to
speak and learn at a public university
in
2023 if those were who were involved in
this mob were able to result to fear
tactics and violence without consequence
what is keeping a pattern of this
despicable behavior from being set and
executed repeatedly this thought
remained on my mind throughout the
planning of a March 2023 event that I
hosted as chairman featuring Michael
nolles this event would grow to gain
more push back than any event on campus
in the previous four years and provide
the most clear-cut examples of freedom
freedom of speech violations this push
back included delays in contract signing
from EB Student Association that
deviated far from their outlined
standard course of action
condemnation of the event by a local New
York state senator and multiple Western
new york-based organizations a
circulated petition constructed by three
University professors calling for the
cancellation of the lecture which gained
thousands of student signatures a forced
venue change orchestrated not only by
University Administration this time but
voted on by a Sunni Council a multitude
of threats in torn literature and even a
tweet from Governor Kathy hok on the day
of the event calling comments from
Michael
dehumanizing the Cry of this event
garnered a responding statement from
University president Sati trapathy
explaining that the constitution
protects speech on campus quote no
matter how noxious the content end quote
it goes on the rest of the testimony is
worth listening to it would be hilarious
if it weren't actually happening right
now head on over to expressvpn.com noes
a few decades ago private citizens used
to be largely that private the internet
has changed everything think about
everything that you've browsed searched
for watched or tweeted all those
Politically Incorrect little searches
that are going to pop up in some
database somewhere and they're going to
send the gapo to come send you to the
goog imagine all that data being trolled
through collected aggregated by Third
parties in a permanent public record
which is your record having your private
life exposed for others to see was once
something that only celebrities worried
about in an era where everyone is online
everyone is a public figure so how do
you keep your data private you go to the
VPN that I trust
expressvpn there are hundreds of data
Brokers out there whose sole business is
to buy and sell your data the worst part
is they don't have to tell you who they
are selling to or get your consent one
of these data points is your IP address
data Harvesters use your IP to uniquely
identify you and your location with
expressvpn your connection gets rered
through an encrypted server and your IP
is masked right now go to expressvpn.com
slns get three extra months for free
this would be a Monty Python sketch this
would be Saturday Night Live bit decades
ago conservative wants to come to campus
to explain that boys and girls are
different and every elected politician
they lose their minds they call it
egregious and then the students who had
the audacity to bring the conservative
speaker are basically tarred and
feathered and run out of town by those
very same authorities this is a scandal
this is a national scandal what do we do
about it well obviously we should defund
we should vote these people out of
office if possible we should defund the
universities that do this kind of stuff
if possible but I don't want to sound
like I'm a utopian or I'm some idealist
here I know that Kathy hokel is not
going to do that I know that the the New
York state government even though there
is a decent Republican representation
there it's not going to do that we're
not going to have a a republican
Governor there certainly not with a
Unified Government anytime soon so what
conservatives have to do is to seek to
establish and fund our own
schools I was talking about the Trump
proposal for the American Academy the
other day a lot of people didn't like it
they say we don't want Government
funding for our schools we don't want an
explicitly pro-conservative school no we
do actually we do that's how the libs
have managed to attain a reasonable
degree of cultural hegemony in recent
years is they took over the existing
institutions and then they fired all
their enemies and then they routed all
of their student enemies and then they
hired all of their friends and then they
got a ton of government funding and then
they changed the rules such that they
could basically never lose power because
because they were in charge of hiring
and they were in charge of firing and
they were in charge of the kangaroo
courts that kick out conservatives for
bogus
reasons and we need to do that we don't
we shouldn't do anything unjust we
shouldn't do anything immoral but but
playing within the extent rules of
politics is not necessarily
unjust being clever is not necessarily
unjust we are told to be wise as
serpents and innocent as doves and very
often conservatives are wise as doves
and innocent as serpents that was V's
big complaint at the top of the debate
yesterday and he was absolutely right
that's what we have to
do we're we're not going to be able to
defund you Buffalo for the madness the
the persecution they put Connor and the
other students through okay well then we
need to when we have any monom of
political power we need to establish
fund and protect our own institutions to
compete against them and Route those
Maniacs out of power man what a great
clip that was now hey hey hey hey hey
hold up ring that Bell subscribe to the
Michael NS podcast see you next time